The task for today is to find
particular solutions.
So, let me remind you where
we've gotten to.
We're talking about the
second-order equation with
constant coefficients,
which you can think of as
modeling springs,
or simple electrical circuits.
But, what's different now is
that the right-hand side is an
input which is not zero.
So, we are considering,
I'm going to use x as your book
does, keeping to a neutral
letter.
But, again, in the
applications,
and in many of the applications
at any rate, it wants to be t.
But, I make it x.
So, the independent variable is
x, and the problem is,
remember, that to find a
particular solution,
and the reason why we want to
do that is then the general
solution will be of the form y
equals that particular solution
plus the complementary solution,
the general solution to the
reduced equation,
which we can write this way.
So, all the work depends upon
finding out what that yp is,
and that's what we're going to
talk about today,
or rather, talk about for two
weeks.
But, the point is,
not all functions that you
could write on the right-hand
side are equally interesting.
There's one kind,
which is far more interesting,
but more important in the
applications than all the
others.
And, that's the one out of
which, in fact,
as you will see later on this
week and into next week,
an arbitrary function can be
built out of these simple
functions.
So, the important function is
on the right-hand side to be
able to solve it when it's a
simple exponential.
But, if you allow me to make it
a complex exponential,
so, here are the important
right-hand sides where we want,
we want to be able to do it
when it's of the form,
e to the ax.
In general, that will be,
in most applications,
a is not a growing exponential,
but a decaying exponential.
So, typically,
a is negative.
But, it doesn't have to be.
I'll put it in parentheses,
though, often.
That's not any assumption that
I'm going to make today.
It's just culture.
But, we want to be able to do
it for sine omega x and cosine
omega x.
In other words,
when the right-hand side is a
pure oscillation,
that's another important type
of input both for electrical
circuits, think alternating
current, or the spring systems.
That's a pure vibration is
you're imposing pure vibration
on the spring-mass-dashpot
system, and you want to see how
it responds to that.
Or, you could put them
together, and make these
decaying oscillations.
So, we could also have
something like e to the ax times
sine omega x,
or times cosine omega x.
Now, the point is,
all of these together are
really just special cases of one
general thing,
exponential,
if you allow the exponent not
to be a real number,
but to be a complex number.
So, they're all special cases
of e to the, I'll write it alpha
x,
well, why don't we write it (a
plus i omega) x, right?
If omega is zero,
then I've got this case.
If a is zero,
I got this case separating into
its real and imaginary parts.
And, if neither is zero,
I have this case.
But, I don't want to keep
writing (a plus i omega) all the
time.
So, I'm going to write that
simply as e to the alpha x.
And, you understand that alpha
is a complex number now.
It doesn't look like a real
number.
Okay, so the complex number.
So, the equation we are solving
is which one?
This pretty purple equation.
And, we are trying to find a
particular solution of it.
And, the special functions we
are going to use are these,
well, this one in particular,
e to the alpha x.
That's going to be our input.
Now, it turns out this is
amazingly easy to do because
it's an exponential because I
write it in exponential form.
The idea is simply to use a
rule which, in fact,
you know already,
the rule of substitution.
So, I'm going to write the
equation in the form,
so, there it is.
It's y double prime plus A y
prime plus B y equals f of x.
But, I'm going to think of the
left-hand side as the polynomial
operator, AD plus B.
A and B are constants,
applied to y equals f of x.
That's the way I write the
thing.
And, this part,
I'm going to think of in the
form.
This is p of D,
a polynomial in D.
In fact, it's a simple
quadratic polynomial.
But, most of what I'm going to
say today would apply equally
well if we were a higher order
polynomial, a polynomial of
higher degree.
And, just to reinforce the
idea, I've given you one problem
in your problem set when p is a
polynomial of higher degree.
I should say,
the notes are written for
general polynomials,
not just for quadratic ones.
I'm simplifying it by leaving
it, today, I'll do what's in the
notes, but I'll do it in the
quadratic case to save a little
time, and because that's the one
you will be most concerned with
in the problems.
All right, so p of D y equals f
of x.
And now, there are just a
couple of basic formulas that
we're going to use all the time.
The first is that if you apply
p of D to a complex
exponential, or a real one,
it doesn't matter,
the answer is you get just what
you started with,
with D substituted by alpha.
So, it's p of alpha.
In other words,
put an alpha wherever you saw a
D in the polynomial.
And, what is this?
Well, this is now just an
ordinary complex number,
and multiply that by what you
started with,
e to the alpha x.
So, that's a basic formula.
It's called in the notes the
substitution rule because the
heart of it is,
you substitute for the D,
you substitute alpha.
Now, this hardly requires
proof.
But, let's prove it just so you
see, to reinforce things and
make things go a little more
slowly to make sure you are on
board all the time.
How would I prove that?
Well, just calculate it out,
what in fact is (D squared plus
AD plus B) times e to the alpha
x.
Well, it's D squared e to the
alpha x by linearity plus AD
times e to the alpha x plus B
times e to the alpha x.
Well, what are these?
What's the derivative of e to
the alpha x?
It's just alpha times e to the
alpha x.
What's a second derivative?
Well, if you remember from the
exam, you can do tenth
derivatives now.
So, the second derivative is
easy.
It's alpha squared times e to
the alpha x.
In other words,
this law, what I'm saying
really is that this law is
obviously, quote unquote,
"true."
Okay, I'm not even going to put
it in quotes.
It's obviously true for the
operator, D, and the operator D
squared.
In other words,
D of e to the alpha x equals
alpha times e to the alpha x.
D squared times e to the alpha
x equals alpha squared times e
to the alpha x.
And, therefore,
it's true for linear
combinations of these as well by
linearity.
So, therefore,
also true for p of D.
And, in fact,
so if you calculate it out,
what is it?
This is alpha squared e to the
alpha x plus alpha e to the
alpha x times the
coefficient plus b times e to
the alpha x.
So, it's in fact exactly this.
It's e to the alpha x times
(alpha squared plus A alpha plus
B).
Now, how are we going to use
this?
Well, the idea is very simple.
Remember, we're trying to solve
this, I should have some
consistent notation for these
equations.
Purple, I think,
will be the right thing here.
You are solving purple
equations.
The formulas which will solve
them will be orange formulas,
and we will see what we need as
we go along.
So, I would like to just
formulate it,
this solution,
the particular solution now.
I'm going to call it a theorem.
It's really too simple to be a
theorem.
On the other hand,
it's too important not to be a
theorem.
So, let's call it,
as I called it in the notes,
the exponential input theorem,
which says it all.
Theorem says it's important.
Exponential input means it's
taking f of x to be an
exponential.
It's an exponential input,
and the theorem tells you what
the response is.
So, for that equation,
I'm not going to recopy the
equation for the purple
equation, adequately indicated
this way.
There.
Now try to take notes.
For the purple equation,
a solution is e to the alpha x.
Somewhere I neglected to say
that f of x, all right,
so for the purple equals e to
the alpha x, how about that?
That equation,
y double prime plus a y prime
plus b y equals e to
the alpha x.
So, here's the exponential
input.
The solution is e to the alpha
x divided by p of alpha.
Now, that's a very useful
formula.
In fact, Haynes Miller,
who also teaches this course,
in his notes calls of the most
important theorem in the course.
Well, I don't have to totally
agree with him,
but it's certainly important.
It's probably the most
important theorem for these two
weeks, anyway.
But, you will have others as
well.
Okay, so that's a theorem.
The theorem is going green.
You can tell what they are by
their color code.
Well, in other words,
what I've done is simply write
down the solution for you,
write down the particular
solution.
But let's verify it in general.
So, the proof would be what?
Well, I have to substitute it
into the equation.
So, the equation is p of D
applied to y is equal to alpha
x.
And, I want to know,
when I substitute that
expression in,
is it the case that when I plug
it in, that the right-hand side,
I calculate it out,
apply p of D to it.
Is it the case that I get e to
the alpha x on the right?
Well, all you have to do is do
it.
What is p of D applied to e to
the alpha x divided by p of
alpha?
Well, p of D applied to e to
the alpha x is p of alpha times
e to the alpha x.
That's the substitution rule.
What about this guy?
This guy is a constant,
so it just gets dragged along
because this operator is linear.
If this applied to that is
this, then if I apply it to one
half that, I get one half the
answer, and so on.
So, the p of alpha
is a constant and just gets
dragged along.
And now, they cancel each
other, and the answer is,
indeed, e to the alpha x.
That's not much of a proof.
I hope that to at least half
this class, you're wondering,
yes, but what if Peter had not
caught the wolf?
I mean, what if?
What if?
I'm looking stern.
Okay, we will take care of it
in the simplest possible way.
We will assume that p of alpha
is not zero.
The case p of alpha is zero
is, in fact,
an extremely important
case, one that makes the world
go 'round, one that contributes
to all sorts of catastrophes,
and they occur first here in
the solution of differential
equations, and that's what
controls all the catastrophes.
But, there's a good side to it,
too.
It also makes a lot of good
things happen.
So, there are no moral
judgments in mathematics.
For the time being,
let's assume p of alpha is not
zero.
And, that proof is okay because
the p of alpha,
being in the denominator,
it's okay to be in the
denominator if you're not zero.
Okay, let's work in a simple
example.
Well, I'm picking the most
complicated example I can think
of.
Simple examples,
I'll leave for your practice
and for the recitations,
can start off with simple
examples if you are confused by
this.
But, let's solve an equation,
find a particular solution.
So, y double prime plus minus y
prime plus 2y is equal to 10 e
to the minus x sine x.
Gulp.
Okay, so, the input is this
function, 10 e to the minus x,
it's a decaying oscillation.
You're seeing those already on
the computer screen if you
started your homework,
if you've done problem one on
your homework.
It's a decaying exponential,
and I want to find a particular
solution.
Well, let's find a particular
and the general solution.
Find the general solution.
Well, the main part of the work
is finding the particular
solution, but let's quickly,
the general solution,
let's find first the
complementary part of it,
in other words,
the solution to the homogeneous
equation.
That's D squared minus D plus
two. No, let's not.
I don't want to solve messy
quadratics.
Okay, we're going to find a
particular solution.
I thought it was going to come
out easy, and then I realized it
wasn't because I picked the
wrong signs.
Okay, so if you don't like,
just change the problem.
I can do that,
but you cannot.
Don't forget that.
So, we want a particular
solution in our equation.
It is this equals that.
Now, let's complexify it to
make this part of a complex
exponential.
So, the complex exponential
that's relevant is ten times e
to the (minus one plus i),
you see that? x.
What is this?
This is the imaginary part of
this complex exponential.
So, this is imaginary part of
that guy, e to the negative x
times e to the i x,
and the imaginary part of e to
the i x.
The ten, of course,
just comes along for the ride.
Okay, well, now,
since this is a complex
equation, I shouldn't call this
y anymore by my notation.
I like to call it y tilde to
indicate that the solution we
get to this is not going to be
the original solution to the
original problem,
but you will have to take the
imaginary part of it to get it.
So, we are looking,
now, for the complex solution
to this complexified equation.
Okay, what is it?
Well, the complex particular
solution I can write down
immediately.
It is ten, that,
of course, just gets dragged
along by linearity,
times e to the (minus one plus
i) times x.
And, it's over this polynomial
evaluated at this alpha.
So, just write it down with,
have faith.
So, what do I get?
The alpha is minus one plus i.
I.
square that,
because I'm substituting this
alpha into that polynomial.
The reason I'm doing that is
because the formula tells me to
do it.
That's going to be that
solution.
Okay, so it's minus one plus i,
the quantity squared, minus
minus one plus i plus two.
All I've done is substitute
minus one plus i for
D in that polynomial,
the quadratic polynomial.
And now, all I want is the
imaginary part of this.
The imaginary part of this will
be the solution to the original
problem because this was the
right hand side with the
imaginary part of the
complexified right hand side.
Okay, now, let's make it look a
little better,
yp tilde.
Clearly, what we have to do
something nice to the
denominator.
So, I'll copy the numerator.
That's e to the minus (one plus
i) x
and how about the denominator?
Well, again,
don't expand things out because
it's already this long.
And, what's the point of making
it this long?
You want to make it as long,
right?
Okay, then there is room here
for one real number,
and another real number times
i, there's no more room.
Okay, what's the real number?
Okay, we're looking for the
real part of this expression.
So, just put it in and keep it
mentally.
So, minus one squared:
that's one, plus i squared,
that's minus one.
One minus one is zero.
I can forget about that term.
The term gives me plus one for
the real part,
plus two.
The answer is that the real
part is three.
How about the imaginary part?
Well, from here,
there's negative 2i,
negative 2i.
I'm expanding that out by the
binomial theorem,
or whatever you like to call
that, minus 2i minus i makes
minus 3i.
Is that right?
Minus 2i, minus i,
minus 3i.
So, it is ten thirds,
and now in the denominator I
have one minus i.
I'll put that in the numerator,
make it one plus i,
but I have to divide by the
product of one minus i and its
complex conjugate.
In other words,
I'm multiplying both top and
bottom by one plus i.
And so, that makes here one
squared plus one squared is two.
And now, what's left is e to
the negative x times cosine x
plus i sine x.
Now, of that,
what we want is just the
imaginary part.
Well, let's see.
Two goes into ten makes five,
so that's five thirds.
So, we're practically at our
solution.
The solution,
then, finally,
is going to be yp is the
imaginary part of yp tilde.
And, what's that?
Well, what's the coefficient
out front, first of all?
It's five thirds,
so let's pull out to five
thirds before we forget it.
And, we'll pull out the e to
the negative x before we forget
that.
And then, the rest is simply a
question of seeing what's left.
Well, it's one.
I want the imaginary part.
So, the imaginary part is going
to be one times cosine x,
and then the other
imaginary part comes from these
two pieces, which is one times
sine x.
And, that should be the
particular solution.
Notice that most of the work is
not getting this thing.
It's turning it into something
human that you can take the real
and imaginary parts of.
If we don't like this form,
you can put it in the other
form, which many engineers would
do almost automatically,
make it five thirds,
e to the negative x,
and what will that be?
Well, you can use the general
formula if you want.
Remember, cosine,
the two coefficients are one
and one, so it's one and one.
So, this is the square root of
two.
So, it is times,
this part makes the square root
of two times cosine of x minus
pi over the angle.
This is a phi.
So, that's pi over four,
minus pi over four.
Okay, all right,
now let's address the case
which is going to occupy a lot
of the rest of today,
and in a certain sense,
all of next time.
What happens when p of alpha is
zero?
Well, in order to be able to
handle this decently,
it's necessary to have one more
formula, which is very slightly
more complicated than the
substitution rule.
But, it's the same kind of
rule.
I'm going to call this,
or it is called the
exponential.
So, I'm going to first prove a
formula, which is the analog of
that, and then I will prove a
green formula,
which is what to do here if p
of alpha turns out to be zero.
But, in order to be able to
prove that, we're going to be
the analog of the orange
formula.
And, the analogue of the orange
formula, that tells you how to
apply p of D to a
simple exponential.
I need a formula which applies
p of D to that simple
exponential times another
function.
Now, I found I got into trouble
by continuing to call that
alpha.
So, I'm now going to change the
name of alpha to change alpha's
name to a.
But, it's still complex.
I don't mean it's guaranteed to
be complex.
I mean it's allowed to be
complex.
So, a is now allowed to be a
complex number.
I'm thinking of it,
in general, as a complex
number, okay?
I hope this doesn't upset you
too much, but you know,
you change x to t's,
and y's to x's.
This is no worse.
All right, what we going to do?
Well, I'm going to use this
exponential shift rule,
I'll call it,
exponential shift rule or
formula or law.
That's the substitution rule
for me.
So, this is going to be
exponential shift law.
And, to apply,
it tells you how to apply the
polynomial to not D,
not just the exponential,
but the exponential times some
function of x.
What's that?
And now, the rule is very
simple.
See, you can understand the
difficulty.
If you try to start
differentiating,
you're going to have to
calculate second derivatives of
the stuff, and God forbid,
higher order equations.
You would have to calculate
fourth derivatives,
fifth derivatives.
You barely even want to
calculate the first derivative.
That's okay.
But, second derivative,
do I have to?
No, not if you know the
exponential shift rule,
which says you can get rid of
the e to the ax,
make it pass to the left of the
operator where it's not in any
position to do any harm any
longer, or upset the
differentiation.
And, all you have to do is,
when it passes over that
operator, it changes D to D plus
a. So, the answer is,
e to the ax.
There, it's passed over.
But, when it did so,
it changed D to D plus a.
And, what about the u?
Well, the u just stayed there.
Nothing happened to it.
Okay, there's our orange
formula.
I guess we better put the thing
around the whole business.
Should I prove that,
or the proof is quite easy.
So, let's do it just again to
give you a chance to try to see,
now, if somebody gives you a
formula like that,
you first stare at it.
You might try a couple of
special cases,
try it on a function and see if
it works, but already,
you probably don't want to do
that.
I mean, even if you took a
function like x here,
you'd have to do a certain
amount of differentiating,
and some quadratic thing here.
You'd calculate and calculate
away for a little while,
and then if you did it
correctly, the two would in fact
turn out to be equal.
But, you would not necessarily
feel any the wiser.
A better procedure in trying to
understand something like this
is say, well,
let's keep the u general.
Suppose we make D simple.
For example,
well, if D is a constant,
of course there's nothing to
happen because if this is just a
constant, both sides of these
are the same.
This doesn't make any sense if
p doesn't really have a D in it.
Well, what's the simplest
polynomial which would have a D
in it?
Well, D itself.
So, let's take a special case.
p of D equals D,
and check the formula in that
case; see if it works.
So, the formula is asking us,
what is D, that's the p of D,
of e to the ax times u?
I'm not going to put in the
variable here because it's just
a waste of chalk.
Well, what is that?
I know how to calculate that.
I'll use the product rule.
So, it's the derivative.
I'll tell you what;
let's do the other order first.
So, it's e to the ax times the
derivative of u plus the
derivative of e to the ax,
which is a times e to the ax
times u.
Do you follow that?
This is the product rule.
It's e to the ax times the
derivative of u plus the
derivative of e to the ax,
which is this thing times u,
the other factor.
Now, is that right?
I want to make it look like
that.
Well, to make it look like that
I should first factor e to the
ax out.
And now, what's left?
Well, if I factor e to the ax
out, what's left is Du plus au,
which is exactly (D plus a)
operating on u,
D u plus a u.
Well, hey, that's just what the
formula said it should be.
If you make e to the x pass
over D, it changes D to
D plus a.
Okay, now here's the main thing
I want to show you.
All right, now,
well let's try,
if this is true,
also works out for D squared,
then the formula is
clearly true by linearity
because an arbitrary p of D
is just a linear
combination with constant
coefficients of D,
D squared, and that constant
thing, which we agreed there was
nothing to prove about.
Now, hack, you're a hack if you
take D squared and start
calculating the second
derivative of this.
Okay, it's question about
hacks.
I mean, it's just,
you haven't learned the right
thing to do.
Okay, that will work,
but it's not what you want to
do.
Instead, you bootstrap your way
up.
I have already a formula
telling me how to handle this.
And, you can be anything.
Look at this not as D squared
all by itself.
Calculate, instead,
D squared e to the ax times u.
Think of that as D,
the derivative of the
derivative of e to the a x u.
In other words,
we will do it one step at a
time.
But you see now immediately the
advantage of this.
What's D of e to the a x u?
Well, I just calculated that.
Now, don't go back to the
beginning.
Don't go back to here.
Use the formula.
After all, you worked to
calculate it,
or I did.
So, it's D of,
and what's this inside?
It's e to the ax times (D plus
a) times u.
Well, that looks like a mess,
but it isn't because I'm taking
D of e to the ax times
something.
And I already know how to take
D of e to the ax times
something.
It doesn't matter what that
something is.
Here, the something was u.
Here, the something is D plus
(a times u) operating on u.
But, the principle is the same,
and the answer is what?
Well, to take D of e to the ax
times something,
you pass the e to the ax over
the D.
That changes D to D plus a.
And, you apply that to the
other guy, which is (D plus a)
applied to u.
What's the answer?
e to the a x times (D plus a)
squared u.
It's just what you would have
gotten if you had taken e to the
e to the x, pass it over,
and then changed D to D plus a.
Now, another advantage to doing
it this way is you can see that
this argument is going to
generalize to D cubed.
In other words,
you would continue on in the
same way by the process of
mathematical,
one word, mathematical,
begins with an I,
induction.
By induction,
you would prove the same
formula for the nth derivative.
If you don't know what
mathematical induction is,
shame on you.
But it's okay.
A lot of you will be able to go
through life without ever having
to learn what it is.
And, the rest of you will be
computer scientists.
Okay, so that's the idea of
this rule.
Now, we can use it to calculate
something.
Let's see, I'm going to need
green for this,
I guess, for our better
formula.
The formula,
now, that tells you what to do
if p of alpha is zero.
So, we're trying to solve the
equation, D squared plus A D,
we are trying to find a
particular solution,
e to the ax,
let's say.
Remember, a is complex.
a could be complex.
It doesn't have to be real.
But, the problem is that p of
alpha is zero.
How do I get a particular
solution?
Well, I will write it down for
you.
So, this is part of that
exponential input theorem.
I think that's the way it is in
the notes.
I gave all the cases together,
but I thought pedagogically
it's probably a little better to
do the simplest case first,
and then build up on the
complexity.
So, what's yp?
The answer is yp is e to the a,
except now you have to multiply
it by x out front.
Where have you done something
like that before?
Yes, don't tell me.
I know you know.
But, what should go in the
denominator?
Clearly not p of alpha.
What goes in the denominator is
the derivative.
Okay, but what if p prime of
alpha is zero?
Couldn't that happen?
Yes, it could happen.
So, we better make cases.
This case is,
the case where this is okay
corresponds to the case where
we're going to assume that alpha
is a simple root,
is a simple root of the
polynomial, p.
I don't know what to call the
variable, p of D is okay.
A simple zero,
in other words,
it's not double.
Well, suppose is double.
One of the consequences you
will see just in a second,
if it's a simple zero,
that means this derivative is
not going to be zero.
That's automatic.
Yeah, well, suppose it's not as
simple.
Well, suppose is a double root.
How did a-- How did that get
changed to, argh!
[LAUGHTER] That's not an alpha.
Oh, well, yes it is,
obviously.
Change!
All of you, I want you to
change.
They should have something like
in a search key where
occurrences of alpha have been
changed to a with a stroke of a,
just your thumb.
They don't have that for the
blackboard, unfortunately.
Well, too bad,
for the future.
Correctable blackboards.
Well, what if a is double root?
It can't be more than a double
root because you've only got a
quadratic polynomial.
Quadratic polynomials only have
two roots.
So, the worst that can happen
is that both of them are a.
All right, in that case the
formula should be yp is equal
to, you are now going to need x
squared up there times e
to the ax,
and in the denominator what you
are going to need is the second
derivative of,
evaluated at a.
Now, you can guess the way this
going to go on.
For higher degree things,
if you've got a triple root,
you will need here x cubed,
except you're going to need a
factorial there,
too.
So, don't worry about it.
It's in the notes,
but I'm not going to give you
that for higher roots.
I don't even know if I will
give it to you for double root.
Yes, I already did,
so it's too late.
It's too late.
Okay, so we will make this two
formulas according to whether a
is a single or a double root.
Okay, let's prove one of these,
and all of that will be good
enough for my conscience.
Let's prove the first one.
Mostly, it's an exercise in
using the first exponential
shift rule.
Okay, this will be a first
example actually seeing a work
in practice as opposed to
proving it.
Okay, so what does that thing
look like?
So, what does the polynomial
look like, which has a as a
simple root?
So, we're going to try to prove
the simple root case.
So, I'm just going to calculate
what those guys actually look
like.
What does p of D look
like if a is a simple root?
Well, if it's a simple root,
that means it has a factor.
When it factors,
it factors into the product of
(D minus a) times something
which isn't, D minus some other
root.
And, the point is that b is not
equal to A.
The roots are really distinct.
Okay, what's,
then, p prime,
I'm going to have to calculate
p prime of a.
What is that?
Well, let's calculate p prime
of D first.
It is, well,
by the ordinary product rule,
it's the derivative of this
times, which is one times (D
minus a) plus,
that's one thing plus the same
thing on the other side,
the derivative of this,
which is one times (D minus b).
So, that's p prime.
And therefore,
what's p prime of a?
It's nothing but,
this part is zero,
and that's a minus b.
Of course, this is not zero
because it's a simple root.
And, that's the proof for you
if you want, that if the root is
simple, that p prime of a
is guaranteed not to
be zero.
And, you can see,
it's going to be zero exactly
when b equals a,
and that root occurs twice.
But, I'm assuming that didn't
happen.
Okay, then all the rest we have
to do is calculate,
do the calculation.
So, what I want to prove now is
that with this p of D,
what I'm trying to calculate
that p of D times that guy,
x e to the a x,
except I'm going to
write it as e to the a x times
x, guess why,
divided by p prime of a.
This is my proposed particular
solution.
So, what I have to do is
calculate it,
and see that it turns out to
be, what do I hope it turns out
to be?
What the right hand side of the
equation, the input?
The input is e to the ax.
If this is true,
then yp, a particular solution,
indeed, nothing will be a
particular solution.
Of course, there could be
others, but in this game,
I only have to find one
particular solution,
and that certainly by far is
the simple as one you could
possibly find.
So, I have to calculate this.
And now, you see why I did the
exponential shift rule because
this is begging to be
differentiated by something
simpler than hack.
Okay, you can also see why I
violated the natural order of
things and put the e to the ax
on the left in order
that it pass over more easily.
So, the answer on the left-hand
side is e to the ax times p of
(D plus a).
Now, what is (p of D) plus a?
Write it in this form.
It's going to be a minus b.
So, p of (D plus a)
is, change D to D plus a.
So, the first factor is going
to be D plus a minus b.
And, what's the second factor?
Change D to D plus a.
It turns into D.
All this is the result of
taking that p of D,
and changing D to D plus a.
And now, this is to be applied
to what?
Well, e to the a x
is already passed over.
So, what's left is x.
And, that's to be divided by
the constant,
p prime of a.
Now, what does this all come
out to be?
e to the ax,
what's D applied to x?
One, right?
And now, what's this thing
applied to the constant one?
Well, the D kills it,
so it has no effect.
It makes it zero.
The rest just multiplies it by
a minus b.
So, the answer to the top is (a
minus b) times one.
And, the answer to the bottom
is p prime of a,
which I showed you by just
explicit calculation is a minus
b.
And so the answer is,
e to the a x comes
out right.
Now, the other one,
the other formula comes out the
same way.
I'll leave that as an exercise.
Also, I don't dare do it
because it's much too close to
the problem I asked you to do
for homework.
So, let's by way of conclusion,
I'll do one more simple
example, okay?
And then, you can feel you
understand something.
I'm sort of bothered that I
haven't done any examples of
this more complicated case.
So, I'll pick an easy version
instead of the one that you have
in your notes,
which is the one you have for
homework, which is even easier.
So, this one's epsilon less
easy.
Y double prime minus 3 y prime
plus 2 y equals e to the x.
Okay, notice that one is a
simple root.
The one I'm talking about is
the a here, which is one.
One is a simple root of the
polynomial D squared minus 3D
plus two,
isn't it?
It's a zero.
Put D equal one and you get
one minus three plus
two equals zero.
It's a simple root because
anybody can see that one is not
a double root because you know
from critical damping,
if one were a double root,
you know just what the
polynomial would look like,
and it wouldn't look like that
at all.
It would not look like D
squared minus 3D plus two.
It would look differently.
Therefore, that proves that one
is a simple root.
Okay, what's the particular
solution, therefore?
The particular solution is x
times e to the x divided by the
derivative, the derivative
evaluated at the point,
so, what's p prime of D?
It is 2D minus three.
If I evaluate it at the point,
one, it is negative one.
So, if this is to be divided by
negative one,
in other words,
it's minus x e to the X.
And, if you don't believe it,
you could plug it in and check
it out.
Okay, I'm letting you out one
minute early.
Remember that.
I'm trying to pay off the
accumulated debt.